so i gotta say waving through window
gets me every time
it gets me every time i'm wondering for
you what song
from this movie from this musical is the
one that makes that
pulls at your heartstrings the most that
brings the tears out
oh
there's so many i mean the new songs
are really really beautiful
um
the the first time i i heard a mandolin
colton song they brought me to tears but
i
i think
words fail
its
words fail is so powerful and the way
ben sings it is just so
incredible and um
he sings it was so much emotion and
heartbreak and it just is
it's just brilliant and getting to watch
that happen live
is a
whole other experience um
i don't know how i don't know how ben
platt
sings the way he does and also cries at
the same time
i don't get it i don't get it yeah like
how is it physically actually possible
biologically possible it's not possible
and somehow then makes it possible
i imagine with you know with ben with
this whole cast
you must have found yourself on on days
even when you weren't filming being like
i wonder if i can just go to set and
just hang out and watch
and and learning
i know well
normally that would be the case i could
just go and hang out but we were
shooting
in the middle of in the middle of a
pandemic and um keeping everything safe
and
so when ben was you know doing scenes
with say amandla or doing scenes alone
um i was just at our house like um
like either making cookies or like
playing legos
[Laughter]
like real actor prep
real
real character work going on some real
stuff no i had to you know there was a
lot of decompressing happening at that
house because there was so much going on
on set that um but yeah no i would i
would i was dying to hang out with
everybody on set but you know because of
all the like and you know very safe
protocols that we were following and
universal kept us very safe the whole
time
we were trying to make sure that we were
socially distancing and staying home as
much as we could and so yeah i was i was
at home
um watching like
hallmark movies and playing legos and
making cookies that's what i was doing
you
you had said in another interview i saw
that you had seen this show previously
not with not with ben in it but you're a
fan
i'm wondering how did spending all that
time with ben
change your approach to the character
and change how you sort of prepped for
it before you got in
and on the project
well
i guess
watching him approach it what was first
was just so cool to be able to see him
take a character that he's played for so
many years and make it seem like he's
you know
he's he's lived it for so long and you
can really really tell that he knows
evan like the back of his hand and he
it is it is so
um
deeply
he has so all of evan like so deeply
rooted inside of him but he was bringing
so many new elements to the character
and so many um
fresh ideas to the character that i was
witnessing you know live but i i i think
coming into it i was a bit i was able to
you know because i've never really been
a part of a project that has existed in
the in the world before and that is so
deeply loved by by
the world and um and i
that is a very daunting um
thing to think about and so coming into
it and meeting ben and you know doing
singing rehearsals with him or doing
scene work with him in prep i was able
to you know just breathe a little bit
better and go okay
you know
ben has lived with this for so long but
he is making me feel so much better
about
um just
like trusting um
[Music]
trusting my prep and trusting the the
hard work that i've put into it and and
um
trusting the process and and
knowing that like i i'm so grateful that
the producers and the director
um put their faith in me to take zoe on
because it's been played by so many
brilliant actresses before me so
um
i i definitely had that in mind but i
was also able to like you know being
with ben and working with him
in prep and especially um it was so
helpful to go okay it's he's
this is
i i feel i feel like everybody is
welcoming me with open arms being a new
member to the team and it was really it
was really really special
yeah
uh another of your
um
co-stars former co-stars that we loved
seeing you with was beanie
obviously in book smart and with her
doing funny girl is there a chance that
the two of you can reunite
for a musical
i would
never turn that down so
whenever that opportunity comes my way i
am saying yes hands down
i would love to sing with beanie
feldstein oh my god that would be so
much fun
oh that would be a dream
it's it's we got to put in the universe
she's good at making it happen she's
good at putting it in the universe and
making things happen so
she is she can she's good at that so
we're putting it out there
you